foreign [Music] it's been called the world's
largest 3D Puzzle but it's not a game the remains
of a British ship that set sail years before
Columbus was rediscovered two decades ago and
that's how long it's taken to try and put it back
together again the BBC's Thomas Morgan has the
story this is a one to ten scale model this is a
same-scale person about a six foot tall person so
this gives you an idea of the size and scale well
I'm above that height so actually gosh I would
just be dwarfed so yeah you imagine at 30 meters
long Wing 25 tons when it's fully rebuilt Newport
will have the only 15th century ship on exhibit
anywhere in the world but with 2 500 individual
pieces the challenge now will be putting it
back together this one is basically like a
huge flat pack jigsaw puzzle without instructions
we have a big challenge here in that this is the
uh really as far as I know the largest attempt
to reconstruct a uh wooden archaeological ship
once it's been dry it started off as hundreds but
now thousands of people are queuing outside and
it's to see this it's about dating back to the
1400s the original wreck was found back in 2002
whilst building for the city's new Arts Center was
taking place on the edge of the river esk workers
came across the remains seven meters deep in mud
and it's taken the best part of 20 years for each
individual piece of wood salvaged to go through
a lengthy process of soaking waxing and drying so
that it can be reassembled safely Toby and his
team believe it was built from Basque Country
Wood launched around 1449 and involved in the
lucrative wine trade between Portugal and Bristol
fell into the water its thought whilst being
repaired in Newport dock later that Century so
this is the wow moment what do you think much of
the ship was dried in Portsmouth on the Naval Base
which is home to the UK and possibly the world's
most famous 16th century ship the Mary Rose
the museum builds around the naval vessel
has been a major tourist attraction for
the city on the south coast and comparisons
between these two ships can easily be drawn
each one of each wreck has got different things
to offer this is a beautiful big ship of a certain
period which is a warship your ship is a smaller
ship but it's a trading vessel of a period That's
earlier that's built in a different way so
you know the significances are that they're
both highly significant this is such an amazing
project and I've got to see it through so even
if it takes decades I'll see this through and
that'll be uh I don't think I have another one
in me I think I'll just finish this and uh retire
the final pieces of wood will be transported from
Portsmouth back to Newport today so the building
process of this the world's largest 3D jigsaw can
finally after two decades begin Thomas Morgan
BBC news for CBS Saturday morning in Newport
to imagine finding something 600 years
old no no and that's size two yeah I
love I love the guy saying you know this
is it you know the incredible amount of
you know intensity putting that together
it's just that's what I was going to say
Jeff said finding it I'm like finding it
putting it back together yeah and then
reconstructing what actually happened
and telling us pretty incredible yeah